the Joe Rogan experience that's very
admirable but I think for some people it
represents our bonding of the community
you know you could have concerts and
lectures and book clubs and I think when
they get together and they talk about
all the values that Jesus proposed if
Jesus is the higher power it gives them
this sort of again moral scaffolding yes
yes well Jesus would probably on the
hill provide a fairly good moral
scaffolding not totally but good right
he was ahead of his time anyway do you
so you do think he was a real person
most of the scholars I've talked to say
he probably was the evidence is not
great of course but I think um I don't
think it's that big a deal actually
because he I mean a wandering preacher
called
Yeshua or Yahshua would it not be
surprising I mean it's a common name and
the plenty of rock wandering preachers
what would be very surprising would be
if he raised Lazarus from the dead and
water and turned water into wine now
that of course didn't did not happen
well why couldn't people just drink
water either why did they have to drink
one he's trying to get people drunk like
what so that was a separate question I I
mean I I think it the point I'm making
is that it's a very big difference as
they did he exists and maybe he did
maybe didn't who cares really
or as that's very different from saying
that a miracle worker right who really
did do miracles rather than conjuring
tricks existed yes
what was the you you said that you wrote
this it's a beginner's guide outgrowing
God well it's for young people I
originally wanted to write a book for
the young children and publishers didn't
want to do that they so they kept
pushing the age range up and Sodhi it
stabilized at about 15 but I think 14
well I what the first chapters been read
by one ten-year-old of my acquaintances
he loved it and I I think it but really
I'm hoping it'll be read by people of
all ages there's um one thing that does
happen to some people that
indoctrinated very young that the
experience is so so negative to them
that they were Bell and they were Bell
and then they seek out other ways of
thinking and then you find them
eventually abandoning them religion
there's a woman named Megan Phelps do
you know she is I think she's Fred
Phelps from the choose his granddaughter
and yes amazing woman yes he wound up
communicating with people through all
things Twitter yes and met her husband
said she rebelled against that father
yes yeah she wanted leaving the church
and wound up realizing that she was
trapped in some sort of a Christian cult
and a very hateful one yes either there
that God hates [ __ ] be exactly Anna and
the same was true of Nate Phelps who was
Fred Phelps his son and he also escaped
he escaped on his 18th birthday well and
and became an atheist and and became I
think he's actually spoken at some of
our conferences from time to time yeah
there's there's hope in that
yes it's just when I like when people
cans and she I've had her on the podcast
she's such a unique woman and she's so
kind and she's so thoughtful and
intelligent it's hard to believe that
she's only been out of this cult for a
few years me Twitter have only been
around here why wasn't she really
inviting why wasn't she ruined by and
why she is so intelligent what how did
she exist in that structure while being
so intelligent I agree
but of course you I feel the same way
about apparently intelligent people who
believe obvious nonsense
yeah and it's it's it's it's hard to
understand
[Applause]